the most exciting guest that came was
ryan's
plus one i'm going on record
if you two break up i will go into
seclusion ryan seacrest's new girlfriend
aubry page has kelly ripa's stamp of
approval oh that's nice
during monday's episode of live with
kelly and ryan the daytime tv host
dished on meeting her co-host's
girlfriend for the first time at her
hubby mark consuelos's birthday party on
friday kelly said uh oh we're all happy
you're here and that you exist because
we weren't sure there wasn't anybody
sure we were starting to be like
maybe he doesn't have a special person
and maybe we should check on him more
often
and it turns out kell likes aubrey so
much that she joked she'll go into
seclusion if the american idol host
breaks up with her
that's exactly what she said
to her i
i mean i said i said that's a compliment
i am so fond of her
as for mark he wanted to know more about
how their romance works since aubry who
is a model is a bit taller than ryan you
know what mark said he pulls me aside he
goes gotta ask you a question she's
really tall
she's she's taller than you and much
taller in heels how does that work
i'm like
what are you asking me he was how's that
work i mean he's like you just have that
dead serious look right he goes because
kelly and i talk about it all the time
what the heck about hype he was so
confused how that's it right he he's
like what about when y'all walk together
whose arm goes where and he just
realized he there's a whole world out
there for him that he never explored
ryan and aubry first sparked dating
rumors in may 2021 when they were
spotted in the hamptons together and
they've managed to keep their love
pretty private ever since but back in
december the tv personality did reveal
to wsj magazine that he has babies on
the brain quote i do want to have kids
but i haven't even gone down that path
which is nuts at my age i think in the
last year it's become clear to me that
yes i do want to do that i want to be
available and present
and it seems like he might be getting a
little practice in with katy perry and
orlando bloom's daughter daisy back in
october katie told et that while her ai
co-stars haven't babysat her little one
yet she's counting on them to teach her
baby girl a few things
i will let lionel take her shopping
and luke will take her fishing yes there
you go and
ryan training i have to be in training
yeah there you go dietician
cooking foodie yep food pizza making yes
i'm gonna use their talents
[Music]
you